voit que l'épidémie elle recule
aujourd'hui on peut le dire au moins en
métropole pourquoi alors vouloir
relancer un débat avec une épidémie qui
régresse parce qu'on arrive à un moment
où vous voyez un pourcentage important
de la population qui est vacciné
quasiment 75 % mais que c'est
insuffisant pour nous permettre de
basculer on va dire dans une épidémie
qui viendra un bruit de fond et donc
comment est ce qu'on gagne les quelques
points de vaccination qui nous manque
bien sûr il ya les verts mais s'est fait
à l'heure actuelle est ce que ça produit
c'est que on est à trente mille nouveaux
accidents par jour donc si on continue à
ce rythme là et bien là protection va
l'atteindre en juillet 2022 donc il faut
accélérer il faut trouver de nouveaux
moyens et c'est pour ça que cet outil
qui a démontré dans d'autres situations
qu'il est efficace on le propose vous
disiez aux accents obligatoires
aujourd'hui ils sont contrôlés
globalement à la crèche à l'école
comment est-ce qu'on contrôlait ce
douzième vaccin qui sera obligatoire
alors il faut pas il faut pas
survalorisé la question du contrôle et
de la sanction vous savez les élus de
nouvelle calédonie ont décidé d'une
obligation vaccinale pour toute la
population qui est effective depuis le 3
septembre et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
quand vous regardez les courbes de
vaccination en nouvelle calédonie ghoul
a comparé par exemple aux antilles où
elle était assez par allen est bien là
en nouvelle calédonie ca a grimpé en
flèche et pourtant il n'y a pas de
sanction pour le moment il n'y a pas de
contrôle il y en aura peut-être l'année
prochaine mais les élus ont décidé du
principe ils ont voté ils ont dit rendez
vous dans deux trois mois et on verra si
on adopte des contrôles et des sanctions
on comprend en fait la proposition de
loi allait davantage sur la question du
principe que l'effectivité par exemple
dans votre rapport vous parlez la mise
en place d'un passeport vaccinale pour
accéder à certains lieux vous ne
précisez pas lesquels c'est parce qu'en
fait il n'y a pas vraiment d'effectivité
de cette mesure c'est plutôt d'envoyer
un signal à l'opinion non c'est une
mesure qui est efficace et comme la
nouvelle calédonie vient de le démontrer
comme la vaccination des enfants l'a
démontré sa a provoqué une hausse mais
il faut derrière effectivement qui est
des contrôles
nous ce qu'on propose c'est la fin du
pass sanitaires ça doit on est terminée
dupas sanitaire qui n'est plus efficace
qui a fonctionné mais qui ne produit
plus vraiment d'effet est par contre oui
quand voudra aller dans un grand
événement dans une salle où il ya 3000
personnes en milieu clos et bien sûr ce
sera normal de contrôler la vaccination
à ce moment là alors on va leur dire
votre texte est examiné ce matin en
commission c'est à dire avant l'examen
en séance il a été rejeté par la
majorité de la droite et du centre vous
regrettez cette position ici
majoritaires au sénat écoutez chacun
prend ses responsabilités moi j'attends
de voir ce que la majorité sénatoriale
dont les votes ont été divers malgré
tout puisqu'une majorité la rejeter mais
certains élus ont voté pour ou se sont
abstenus ce qui montre qu'il ya un débat
sur tous les bancs que la réponse n'est
pas simple et vous savez dans la vie
politique et qu'on s'occupe des français
c'est pas une mesure où ou rien il faut
dire ce qu'on fait sinon si
l'alternative ceux de compte il continué
le pass sanitaire jusqu'en juillet 2022
même avec une clause de revoyure au mois
de février moi je crains que ce soit
inefficace pour arrêter une vague
hivernale donc en face je n'ai pas
entendu de propositions berlin - vous
êtes la cible de beaucoup d' attaques
sur les réseaux sociaux depuis vous fait
cette proposition comment est ce que
vous expliquez cette hystérisation du
débat public autour de la vaccination
vous savez l'extrême droite parce que
c'est l'extrême droite dont il s'agit a
décidé de s'emparer du vaccin comme d'un
symbole de lutte
contre les autorités sanitaires contre
les autorités politiques au fond contre
notre démocratie eh ben on lutte contre
l'extrême droite c'est tout
[Musique]